son champion d'europe en salle par
équipes valentin ripaud et thomas chiron
ont participé au concours de tir à l'arc
organisé par les archers de guyancourt
une compétition pour se tester en vue de
la prochaine saison
cette année je passais seniors les
niveaux quand même un peu plus élevé il
ya beaucoup plus de monde donc c'est
quand même mieux de faire ces petits
changements là qui donnera peut-être le
point en plus ce qui me manquera où les
petits détails
mon objectif en venant ici c'est
premièrement de me préparer pour la
suite et après donc c'est de faire le
maximum de matchs possible et je pense
que je peux aller au bout et thomas
shiro a accompli son objectif il a
remporté le tournoi catégorie senior arc
classique un format sur le modèle des
compétitions internationales avec des
duels entre les archers de préparer tous
les sportifs de haut niveau
aux championnats régionaux france ou
voire internationaux on a mis en place
cette compétition à côté des
professionnels les archers amateurs
relèvent leur niveau du club d'elancourt
emilie coupé utilise un arc à poulies la
spécificité une puissance supérieure à
l'arc classique perna comme j'ai eu des
petits soucis de santé j'ai changé de
matériel à la dernière minute donc c'est
me faire plaisir et vraiment essayé de
me focaliser sur les points sans
pression avec un nouvel arc à poulies
emilie a remporté le tournoi dans sa
catégorie